a philosophy of language
your linguistic discoveries have led you
to take positions in philosophy of
language and in what is called
philosophy of knowledge
in particular in your last book
Reflections on language
you were induced to determine the limits
of what is knowable in thought
as a result the reflections on language
became transformed virtually into a
philosophy of science
of course it is not the study of
language that determines what is to
count as a scientific approach
but in fact this study provides a useful
model to which one can refer in the
investigation of human knowledge
in the case of language one must explain
how an individual presented with quite
limited data develops an extremely rich
system of knowledge
the child placed in a linguistic
Community is presented with a set of
sentences that is limited and often
imperfect fragmented and so on in spite
of this in a very short time he succeeds
in constructing and internalizing the
grammar of his language developing
knowledge that is very complex that
cannot be derived by induction or
abstraction from what is given an
experience
we conclude that the internalized
knowledge must be limited very narrowly
by some biological property whenever we
encounter a similar situation
where knowledge is constructed from
limited and imperfect data in a manner
that is uniform and homogeneous among
all individuals
we can conclude that a set of initial
constraints plays a significant role in
determining the cognitive system which
is constructed by the mind
we find ourselves faced with what may
seem a paradox
though it is in fact not a paradox at
all
where rich and complex knowledge can be
constructed in a uniform way
as in the case of knowledge of language
there must exist constraints
limitations imposed by biological
endowment on the cognitive systems that
can be developed by the mind
the scope of attainable knowledge is
linked in a fundamental way with its
limits
if all kinds of grammatical rules were
possible then the acquisition of these
rules would become impossible
if all combinations of phonemes were
possible there would no longer be
language
the study of language shows on the
contrary to what extent the sequential
combinations of words of phonemes are
limited that these combinations form
only a small subset of the set of
imaginable combinations
Linguistics must render explicit the
rules which limit these combinations but
on the basis of these limits one obtains
an Infinity of language forms
if sharp limits on attainable knowledge
did not exist
we could never have such extensive
knowledge as that of language
for the simple reason that without these
prior limitations
we could construct an enormous number of
possible systems of knowledge each
compatible with what is given an
experience
so the uniform attainment of some
specific system of knowledge that
extends far beyond experience would be
impossible
we might adopt different cognitive
systems with no possibility of
determining which of these systems is in
fact the right one
if we have a considerable number of
theories that are comparable in
credibility
that is virtually the same as having no
Theory at all
let us suppose that we discover a domain
of intelligence where human beings Excel
if someone has developed a rich
explanatory theory in spite of the
limitations of available evidence
it is legitimate to ask what the general
procedure is that has permitted this
move from experience to knowledge
what is the system of constraints that
has made possible such an intellectual
leap
The History of Science might provide
some relevant examples
at certain times Rich scientific
theories have been constructed on the
basis of limited data theories that were
intelligible to others consisting of
propositions Linked In some manner to
the nature of human intelligence
given such cases we might try to
discover the initial constraints that
characterize these theories
that leads us back to posing the
question
what is the universal grammar for
intelligible theories
what is the set of biologically given
constraints
suppose we can answer this question
in principle that might be possible
then the constraints being given we can
inquire into the kinds of theories that
can in principle be attained
this amounts to the same thing as when
we ask in the case of language
given a theory of universal grammar what
types of languages are in principle
possible
let us refer to the class of theories
made available by the biological
constraints as accessible theories
it may be that this class will not be
homogeneous
that there will be degrees of
accessibility
accessibility relative to other theories
Etc
in other words the theory of
accessibility may be more or less
structured
the universal grammar for Theory
Construction
is then a theory of the structure of
accessible theories
if this Universal grammar is part of the
biological endowment of a person than
given appropriate evidence the person
will in some cases at least have certain
accessible theories available
admittedly I'm simplifying greatly
consider them the class of true theories
we can imagine that such a class exists
expressed let us say in some notation
available to us
then we can ask
what is the intersection of the class of
accessible theories and the class of
true theories
that is to say which theories belong at
the same time to the class of accessible
theories and to the class of true
theories
or we can raise more complex questions
about degree of accessibility and
relative accessibility
where such an intersection exists a
human being can attain real knowledge
and conversely he cannot attain real
knowledge beyond that intersection
of course this is on the assumption that
the human mind is part of nature that it
is a biological system like others
perhaps more intricate and complex than
others that we know about but a
biological system nevertheless
with its potential scope and its
intrinsic limits determined by the very
factors that provide its scope
human reason on this view is not the
universal instrument that Descartes took
it to be but rather a specific
biological system
we come back again to the idea According
to which scientific activity is not
possible except within the biological
limits of the human being
but notice that there is no particular
biological reason why such an
intersection should exist
the capacity to invent Nuclear Physics
provides an organism with no selectional
advantage and was not a factor in human
evolution it is reasonable to assume
the ability to solve algebra problems is
not a factor in differential
reproduction
there is to my knowledge no credible
version of The View that these special
capacities are somehow continuous with
practical abilities tool making and the
like
which is not to deny of course
that these special capacities developed
for unknown reasons as a concomitant of
evolution of the brain that may have
been subject to selectional pressures
in a sense the existence of an
intersection of the class of accessible
theories and the class of true theories
is a kind of biological miracle
it seems that this miracle took place at
least in one domain namely physics and
the natural science is that one might
think of loosely as a kind of extension
of physics
chemistry biochemistry molecular biology
in these domains progress has been
extremely rapid on the basis of limited
data and in a manner intelligible to
others
perhaps we are confronted here with a
unique episode in human history
there is nothing to lead one to believe
that we are a universal organism
rather we are subject to biological
limitations with respect to the theories
we can devise and comprehend
and we are fortunate to have these
limitations
for otherwise we cannot construct Rich
systems of knowledge and understanding
at all
but
these limitations May well exclude
domains about which we would like very
much to know something
that's too bad
perhaps there is another organism with a
differently organized intelligence that
would be capable of what we are not
this is as a first approximation a
reasonable one in my opinion
a way to think about the question of
acquisition of conscious knowledge
going a step further it is not
unimaginable that a particular organism
might come to examine its own system of
acquiring knowledge
it might thus be able to determine the
class of intelligible theories which it
can attain
I don't see any contradiction in that
a theory which is found to be
unintelligible
an inaccessible theory in the sense just
given
does not thereby become intelligible or
accessible
it would simply be identified
and if in some domain of thought the
accessible theories turn out to be
remote from the true theories
that's too bad
then human beings can at best develop a
kind of intellectual technology
which for inexplicable reasons predicts
certain things in these domains
but they won't truly understand why the
technology is working
they will not possess an intelligible
theory in the sense that an interesting
science is intelligible
their theories
though perhaps effective will be
intellectually unsatisfied
looking at the history of the human
intellectual Endeavor from this point of
view
we find curious things surprising things
in mathematics certain areas seem to
correspond to exceptional human
aptitudes number Theory spatial
intuition
pursuit of these intuitions determine
the main line of progress in mathematics
until the end of the 19th century at
least
apparently our mind is capable of
handling the abstract properties of
number systems abstract geometry and the
mathematics of the continuum
these are not the absolute limits but it
is probable that we are confined to
certain branches of science in
mathematics
presumably all that I have just said
would be rejected by a strict empiricist
or even regarded as senseless
that is to say by someone who believes
in the proposition According to which
man proceeds by induction and
generalization in the acquisition of
knowledge starting from empty or blank
Minds without a priori biological
limitations
within that framework knowledge is no
more determined by the structure of the
Mind
than is the form of a design by the wax
tablet
yes these empiricist hypotheses have
very little plausibility in my opinion
it does not seem possible to account for
the development of Common Sense
understanding of the physical and social
world
or science
in terms of processes of induction
generalization abstraction and so on
there is no such direct path from data
that are given to intelligible theories
the same is true in other domains music
for example
after all you can always imagine
innumerable musical systems
most of which will seem to the human ear
to be just noise
there are two biological factors
determine the class of possible musical
systems for human beings
though what exactly this class may be is
an open and currently debated question
in this case as well no direct
functional explanation seems available
ability is not a factor in reproduction
music does not improve material
well-being does not permit one to
function better in society Etc
quite simply
it responds to the human need for
aesthetic expression
if we study human nature in a proper way
we may discover that certain musical
systems correspond to that need
While others do not
among those fields in which the
scientific approach has not made any
progress in two thousand years
you list the study of human behavior
Behavior yes that is one such case
the basic questions have been posed
since the beginning of historical memory
the question of causation of behavior
seems simple enough to pose but
virtually no theoretical progress has
been made in answering it
one might formulate the basic question
as follows
consider a function of certain variables
such that given the values of the
variables the function will give us the
behavior that results under the
conditions specified by these values or
perhaps some distribution over possible
behaviors
but no such function has been seriously
proposed even to a weak approximation
and the question has remained without
issue in fact we don't know of any
reasonable way to approach the problem
it is conceivable that this persistent
failure is to be explained on the
grounds that the true theory of behavior
is beyond our cognitive reach
therefore we can make no progress
it would be as if we tried to teach a
monkey to appreciate Bach
a waste of time
then the question of behavior would be
different from the question of syntax
that too had never been posed before the
development of generative grammar
but in this case once the question is
posed
everyone comes up with answers that are
similar or comparable
when certain questions are posed
sometimes the answer is impossible to
imagine
sometimes answers begin to appear quite
widely
and when an answer is proposed those who
have an adequate understanding of the
question will also regard the answer as
intelligible
it is often the case that a question
cannot yet properly be posed or posed
with the requisite degree of
sophistication
but then it can sometimes be posed
properly and still seem to lie beyond
our intellectual grasp
another analog to the case of language
perhaps is our comprehension of the
social structures in which we live
we have all sorts of tacit and complex
knowledge concerning our relations to
other people
perhaps we have a sort of universal
grammar of possible forms of social
interaction
and it is this system which helps us to
organize intuitively our imperfect
perceptions of social reality
though it does not follow necessarily
that we are capable of developing
conscious theories in this domain
through the exercise of our
science-forming faculties
if we succeed in finding our place
within our society
that is perhaps because these societies
have a structure that we are prepared to
seek out
with a little imagination we could
devise an artificial Society
in which no one could ever find his
place
then you can compare the failure of
artificial languages with the failure of
utopian societies
perhaps
one cannot learn an artificial language
constructed to violate Universal grammar
as readily as one learns in natural
language
simply by being immersed in it
at most one might conceive of such a
language as a game a puzzle in the same
way we can imagine a society in which no
one could survive as a social being
because it does not correspond to
biologically determined perceptions and
Human Social needs
for historical reasons existing
societies might have such properties
leading to various forms of pathology
any serious social science or theory of
social change
must be founded on some concept of human
nature
a theorist of Classical liberalism such
as Adam Smith Begins by affirming that
human nature is defined by a propensity
to truck and barter to exchange goods
that assumption Accords very well with
the social order he defends
if you accept that premise
which is hardly credible
it turns out that human nature conforms
to an idealized early capitalist Society
without Monopoly without State
intervention and without social control
of production
if on the contrary you believe with Marx
or the French and German Romantics that
only social cooperation permits the full
development of human powers
then you will have a very different
picture of a desirable Society
there is always some conception of human
nature implicit or explicit underlying a
doctrine of social order or social
change
to what degree can your discoveries
about language and your definitions of
fields of knowledge lead to the
emergence of new philosophic questions
to which philosophy do you feel closest
in relation to the questions we have
just been discussing
the philosopher to whom I feel closest
and whom I'm almost paraphrasing is
Charles Sanders Pierce
he proposed an interesting outline very
far from complete of what he called
abduction
abduction is I believe a form of
inference which does not depend solely
on apriori principles like deduction nor
solely on experimental observation like
induction
but that aspect of peers is very little
known in France
or here in the United States either
Pierce argued that to account for the
growth of knowledge one must assume that
man's mind has a natural adaptation to
imagining correct theories of some kinds
some principle of abduction which puts a
limit on admissible hypothesis
a kind of instinct developed in the
course of evolution
Pierce's ideas on abduction were rather
vague and his suggestion that
biologically given structure plays a
basic role in the selection of
scientific hypotheses
seems to have had very little influence
to my knowledge almost no one has tried
to develop these ideas further
although similar Notions have been
developed independently on various
occasions
Pierce has had enormous influence but
not for this particular reason
more in semiology
yes in that general area
his ideas on abduction developed kantian
ideas to which recent anglo-american
philosophy has not been very receptive
as far as I know his approach in
epistemology has never been followed up
even though there has been much
criticism of inductivist approaches
popper for example
Russell for his part was much
preoccupied in his later work human
knowledge with the inadequacy of the
empiricist approach to the acquisition
of knowledge
but this book has generally been ignored
he proposed various principles of
non-demonstrative inference
with the aim of accounting for the
knowledge which in reality we possess
non-demonstrative inference differs from
the deductions of mathematical logic to
the degree where in spite of the truth
of the premises and the rigorous
character of the reasoning
the truth of the conclusions is not
guaranteed
they are only rendered probable
is that it
in substance yes one might say that his
approach here was kantian to a certain
degree
but with fundamental differences
in some way
Russell remained an empiricist his
principles of non-demonstrative
inference are added one by one to the
fundamental principle of induction
and do not offer a radical change in
perspective
but the problem is not quantitative it
is qualitative
the principles of non-demonstrative
inference do not fulfill the need
I believe a radically different approach
is necessary which takes a startling
point that is quite remote from
empiricist presuppositions
that is true not only for scientific
knowledge where it is generally accepted
today
but also for what we can call the
constructions of Common Sense
understanding
that is for our ordinary Notions
concerning the nature of the physical
and social world
our intuitive comprehension of human
actions their ends their reasons and
their causes Etc
these are very important issues
which would demand much more analysis
than I can give here
but to return to your question
a great deal of the work of contemporary
philosophers on language and the nature
of scientific research has been very
stimulating for me
my own work from the very beginning
was greatly influenced by developments
in philosophy
as the published acknowledgments of
indebtedness indicate particularly to
Nelson Goodman and W V Quine
and that continues to be true
to mention only a few examples
the work of John Austin on speech acts
proved very fruitful
as well as that of Paul Grice on the
logic of conversation
at present very interesting work is
being pursued on the theory of meaning
along various lines
one can cite the contribution of Saul
Kripke
Hillary Putnam
Gerald Katz Michael dummett Julius
moravchik Donald Davidson and many
others
certain of the work on eye semantics the
study of Truth and possible worlds seems
promising in particular
I would mention the work of Jaco hintika
and his colleagues which deals with
questions that are Central to quite a
range of topics in syntax and semantics
of natural languages
particularly with regard to
quantification
such work has also been extended to
pragmatics
that is to the study of the manner in
which language is used to accomplish
certain human ends
for example
the work of the Israeli philosopher
as these few brief references indicate
this work is being done on an
international scale
and is not just anglo-american
I should also mention work on history
and philosophy of science which has
begun to furnish a richer and more exact
understanding of the manner in which
ideas develop and take root in the
Natural Sciences
this work for example
that of Thomas Kuhn or imray lacatos has
gone well beyond the often artificial
models of verification and falsification
which were prevalent for a long time
and which exercised a dubious influence
on the soft Sciences
as the latter did not rest on the
foundations of a healthy intellectual
tradition that could guide their
development
it is useful in my opinion for people
working in these fields to become
familiar with ways in which the Natural
Sciences have been able to progress
in particular to recognize how at
critical moments of their development
they have been Guided by radical
idealization
the concern for depth of insight and
explanatory power rather than by concern
to accommodate all the facts
a notion that approaches meaninglessness
even at times disregarding apparent
counter-examples in the Hope which at
times has proven Justified only after
many years or even centuries
that subsequent insights would explain
them
these are useful lessons but have been
obscured in much of the discussion about
epistemology and the philosophy of
science
what do you think of European
philosophers of the French in particular
outside of anglo-american philosophy I
do not know enough about contemporary
philosophers to discuss them at all
seriously
have you ever met any french Marxist
philosophers
rarely
here are some distinctions are necessary
contemporary Marxist philosophy has been
linked in large part to leninist
Doctrine at least until recently
European Marxism after World War One
developed unfortunate tendencies in my
opinion the Tendencies associated with
bolshevism
which has always seemed to me an
authoritarian and reactionary current
the latter became dominant within the
European Marxist tradition after the
Russian Revolution
but much more to my taste at least are
quite different tendencies
for example that range of opinion that
extends roughly from Rosa Luxembourg and
the Dutch Marxist Anton panicok and Paul
Matick to the anarcho-syndicalist
Rudolph rocker and others
these thinkers have not contributed to
philosophy in the sense of our
discussion
but they have much to say about Society
about social change and the fundamental
problems of human life
though not about problems of the sort
that we have been discussing for example
Marxism itself has become too often a
sort of church
a theology
of course I'm generalizing far too much
work of value has been done by those who
consider themselves marxists
but up to a certain point this criticism
is Justified I'm afraid
in any case
I do not believe that Marxist philosophy
of whatever tendency has made a
substantial contribution to the kind of
questions we have been discussing
for the rest
what I know has not impressed me greatly
it has not encouraged me to seek to know
more
but you met Michelle Foucault I believe
during a television broadcast in
Amsterdam
yes and we had some very good
discussions before and during the
broadcast
on Dutch television we spoke for several
hours
he in French and I in English
I don't know what the Dutch television
viewers made of all that
we found ourselves in at least partial
agreement it seemed to me on the
question of human nature and perhaps not
as much on politics
the two basic points about which font's
Elders interviewed us
as far as the concept of human nature
and its relation to Scientific progress
was concerned
it seemed that we were
climbing the same Mountain starting from
opposite directions
to repeat a simile which Elders
suggested
in my view scientific creativity depends
on two facts on the one hand
on an intrinsic property of mind
and on the other on a combination of
Social and intellectual conditions
there is no question of choosing between
these
in order to understand the scientific
discovery
it is necessary to understand the
interaction between these factors
but personally
I am more interested in the first
while Foucault stresses the second
Foucault considers the scientific
knowledge of a given Epoch to be like a
grid of Social and intellectual
conditions
like a system the rules of which permit
the creation of new knowledge
in his View
if I understand him correctly
human knowledge is transformed due to
social conditions and social struggles
with one grid replacing the other
thus bringing new possibilities to
science
he is I believe skeptical about the
possibility or the legitimacy of an
attempt to place important sources of
human knowledge within the human mind
conceived in an a historical manner
his position also involves a different
usage of the term Cree activity
when I speak of creativity in this
context
I am not making a value judgment
creativity is an aspect of the ordinary
and daily use of language and if Human
Action in general
however when Foucault speaks of
creativity he is thinking more of the
achievements of a Newton for example
although he stresses the common social
and intellectual base for the creations
of scientific imagination rather than
the achievements of an individual genius
that is to say he is thinking of the
conditions for radical innovation
his use of the term is a more normal one
than mine
but
even if contemporary science may find
some solution to problems relating to
ordinary normal creativity
and I am rather skeptical even about
this
still it cannot hope certainly to be
able to come to grips with true
creativity in the more usual sense of
the word or say to foresee the
achievements of great artists or the
future discoveries of science
that seems a hopeless quest in my
opinion the sense in which I am speaking
of normal creativity is not unlike what
Descartes had in mind when he made the
distinction between a human being and a
parrot
in the historical perspective of
Foucault
one no longer seeks to identify the
innovators and their specific
achievement or the obstacles which stand
in the way of the emergence of Truth
but to determine how knowledge as a
system independent of individuals
modifies its own rules of formation
in defining the knowledge of an Epoch as
a grid or system doesn't Foucault draw
near to structuralist thought
which also conceives of language as a
system
to reply properly it would be necessary
to study this matter in depth
in any case while I have been speaking
of the limitations imposed on a class of
accessible theories
linked to the limitations of the human
mind that permit the construction of
Rich theories in the first place
he is more interested in the
proliferation of theoretical
possibilities resulting from the
diversity of social conditions within
which human intelligence can flourish
in the same way structuralist
Linguistics stresses the differences
between languages
I have to be cautious in response
because the expression structural
Linguistics can cover a great variety of
positions
it is certainly true that American Neo
bloomfieldian linguists who sometimes
call themselves structuralists have been
impressed Above All by the diversity of
languages
and that some of them like Martin yoss
have gone so far as to declare as a
general proposition of linguistic
science
that languages can differ from one
another in an arbitrary manner
when they speak of universals this
involves a characterization of a very
limited nature perhaps some statistical
observations
on the other hand such a
characterization would be very wide of
its Mark in the case of other schools of
structural linguistics
for example the work of Roman Jacobson
who has always been concerned with
linguistic universals which narrowly
constrain the class of possible
languages
especially in phonology
as far as Foucault is concerned as I've
said he seems skeptical about the
possibility of developing a concept of
human nature that is independent of
Social and historical conditions
as a well-defined biological concept
I don't believe that he would
characterize his own approach as
structuralist
I don't share his skepticism I would be
in agreement with him in saying that
human nature is not as yet within the
range of science
up to the present it has escaped the
reach of scientific inquiry but I
believe that in specific domains such as
the study of language
we can begin to formulate a significant
concept of human nature
in its intellectual and cognitive
aspects in any case I would not hesitate
to consider the faculty of language as
part of human nature
did you and Foucault speak of the Paul
while grammar General
more precisely about my relationship to
the work on the history of ideas
there are a number of misunderstandings
on this subject
these questions can be approached in
various ways
my approach to the early modern
rationalist tradition for example
is not that of a historian of science or
a philosophy
I have not attempted to reconstruct in
an exhaustive manner what people thought
at that time
but rather to bring to light certain
important insights of the period that
have been neglected and often seriously
distorted in later scholarship
and to show how at that time certain
persons had already discerned important
things
perhaps without being fully aware of it
these specific intentions are spelled
out quite explicitly in my book
Cartesian Linguistics for example
I was interested in earlier stages of
thought and speculation relating to
questions of contemporary significance
and I try to show in what ways and to
what extent similar ideas were
formulated
anticipations of later developments
perhaps from rather different
perspectives
I think that we can often see from our
current vantage point in the progress of
understanding how a thinker of the past
was groping towards certain extremely
significant ideas
frequently in a very constructive and
remarkable manner and perhaps with only
a partial awareness of the nature of his
quest
let me offer an analogy
I am not proceeding in the manner of an
art historian so much as that of an art
lover
person who looks for what has value to
him in the 17th century for example
that value deriving in large measure
from the Contemporary perspective with
which he approaches these objects
both types of approach are legitimate I
think it is possible to turn toward
earlier stages of scientific knowledge
and by virtue of what we know today
to shed light on the significant
contributions of the period in a way in
which the most creative Geniuses could
not because of the limitations of their
time
this was the nature of my interest in
Descartes for example and in the
philosophical tradition that he
influenced and also Humboldt
who would not have considered himself a
Cartesian
I was interested in his effort to make
sense of the concept of free creativity
based on a system of internalized rules
an idea that has certain roots in
Cartesian thought I believe
the kind of approach I was taking has
been criticized but not on any rational
ground so far as I can see
perhaps I should have discussed the
nature and legitimacy of such an
approach in more detail
though it seemed to me and still seems
to me obvious
what I've been saying is quite familiar
in the history of science
for example Dexter house in his major
work on the origins of classical
mechanics points out with reference to
Newton that properly speaking the whole
system can only be understood in the
light of the subsequent development of
the science
suppose that the insights of classical
mechanics had been lost
and there had been a reversion to
something more akin to Natural History
the accumulation and organization of
large amounts of data and phenomenal
observations
perhaps a kind of Babylonian astronomy
though even this reference is probably
unfair
then suppose that in some new phase of
science questions similar to those of
the period of classical mechanics had
re-emerged
it would then have been entirely
appropriate quite important in fact to
try to discover significant insights of
an earlier period and to determine in
what ways they were anticipations of
current work
perhaps to be understood properly in the
light of subsequent developments
this it seems to me is more or less what
happened in the study of language and
mind
and I think it is quite interesting to
recover insights that have long been
neglected approaching earlier work which
has often been grossly misrepresented as
I showed from the standpoint of current
interests and trying to see how
questions discussed in an earlier period
can be understood
and sometimes reinterpreted in the light
of more recent understanding knowledge
and technique
this is a legitimate approach not to be
confused with efforts like those of
Dexter house in physics
to reconstruct exactly how the issues
appeared and how ideas were constructed
at an earlier time
of course one must be careful not to
falsify earlier discussion
but I am aware of no critical analysis
of my work that shows this to be the
case
there has I am sorry to say that a good
deal of outright misrepresentation of
what I wrote
in what is called the scholarly
literature
and I have been surprised to find
criticism of my alleged views even on
topics that I did not discuss at all
I have commented occasionally on some of
these falsifications
as have others but by no means
exhaustively and I won't pursue it here
any person engaged in intellectual work
can do the same thing with himself
you can try to reconsider what you
understood 20 years ago and thus see in
what direction in a confused manner you
were striving to go
toward what goal that perhaps became
clear and intelligible only much later
what were the political disagreements
between you and Foucault
for my part I would distinguish two
intellectual tasks
one is to imagine a future society that
conforms to the exigencies of human
nature
as best we understand them
the other
to analyze the nature of power and
oppression in our present societies
for him if I understand him rightly
what we can imagine now is nothing but a
product of the Bourgeois Society of the
modern period
the Notions of Justice or of realization
of the human essence
are only the inventions of our
civilization
and result from our class system
the concept of justice is thus reduced
to a pretext Advanced by a class that
has or wants to have access to power
the task of a reformer or revolutionary
is to gain power
not to bring about a more just Society
questions of abstract Justice are not
posed and perhaps cannot even be posed
intelligibly
Foucault says again if I understand him
correctly
that one engages in the class struggle
to win
not because that will lead to a more
just Society
in this respect I have a very different
opinion
a social struggle in my view can only be
justified if it is supported by an
argument
even if it is an indirect argument based
on questions of fact and value that are
not well understood
which purports to show that the
consequences of the struggle will be
beneficial for human beings
and will bring about a more decent
Society
let us take the case of violence
I am not a committed pacifist and thus
do not say that it is wrong to use
violence in all circumstances say in
self-defense
but any recourse to violence must be
justified
perhaps by an argument that it is
necessary to remedy Injustice
if a revolutionary victory of the
proletariat were to lead to putting the
rest of the world into crematoria then
the class struggle is not justified it
can only be justified by an argument
that it will bring an end to class
oppression
and do so in a way that Accords with
fundamental human rights
complicated questions arise here no
doubt but they should be faced
we were an apparent disagreement
because where I was speaking of Justice
he was speaking of power
at least
that is how the difference between our
points of view appeared to me